hydro refile la facture aux québécois en
augmentant les tarifs c'est pas mal plus
que nos organisations salaise sur sanne
groupe
la facture d'électricité c'est toujours
une question délicate
on recevait le grand patron
d'hydro-québec il ya quelques jours sur
ce plateau est immanquablement les
questions pleuvent exemple celle de
louise baribeau pourquoi payons nous
aussi cher l'électricité
si nous avons des surplus et que c'est
notre richesse est-ce que l'électricité
est vraiment chère au québec
non c'est pas le cas lui c'est jean
thomas bernard professeur de sciences
économiques à l'université d'ottawa en a
un des tarifs les plus bas au monde et
le plus bas en amérique du nord 100 $
d'électricité à montréal ça vaut 442 à
boston ou encore 427 à new york
230 à halifax le plus proche compétiteur
du québec c'est le manitoba avec 126
dollars et en europe
378 dollars à londres 306 à paris et en
plus
l'augmentation est resté proche de
l'inflation en pointillés sur ce
graphique si on regarde la croissance
des prix de vente et à l'électricité
seulement 26% devant le panier
d'alimentation à l'épicerie ses 62 pour
ça et d'essence à la pompe
4 2 pour ça dans la question ont demandé
si les québécois ne pourrait pas avoir
un rabais qu'il y a des surplus hydro
québec verse environ 2 milliards de
dollars par année au gouvernement ce qui
sert à financer la santé l'éducation les
transports
chiant on coupait les tarifs des
nacelles couperet d'un gildan la découpe
et là ça voudrait dire que goldman
devraient chercher d'autres sources de
revenus comme par exemple augmenter les
impôts
est ce que les québécois seraient
vraiment gagnant